but I've seen you do James Mason they
don't put you in makeup when you do
James Mason because the impression is so
dead on oh thank you very much but then
sometimes they'll give you makeup and
the makeup when you do John Malkovich
yeah the makeup actually how it makes
the impression without a doubt if
they're making you up as John Malkovich
does it take hours I mean no no those
guys Louis and Josh the makeup
Department they're so they're so good
they will also I remember one time I was
a doctor and a sketch Hugh Laurie
Halloween show I remember and I was a
doctor in a sketch and the next sketch I
was Frankenstein right and they had a
minute oh wow and I walked around the
corner there's like eight guys with tons
and they said close your eyes put your
arms up listen I just went like this
green makeup yeah it was like yeah still
changing the tires and there yeah lift
up your left foot left foot you know I'm
like sorry guys sorry you know and
then they push you out there and then
you're like okay now I once was there
and I watched them doing all the set
changes and stuff and I'm always I think
that's even a better show yeah to see
everything that goes on in terms of the
transition I see they try to incorporate
a little of that in some of the bumpers
but yeah you see how crazy well my dad
for the my second to last show because I
was going to go it was in the cold open
and I got to say live from New York and
I was like hey Dad you know come out on
the floor and you'll get to watch it
live and he goes I want to see you say
live from New York live that'd be really
cool you know and um he said the minute
it happened you know when the Montage
and just this big wall you got he got
you know he got stuck behind a wall
where's my dad I'm like where is he
they're like oh he's back there and they
had to move the wall these guys like ah
sorry sorry sir come on into my dad was
like oh that's all right meanwhile
you're doing Saturday Night Live and
you're worrying about your father I know
they're doing they're taking the wigs
off me I'm like no him him right there
get him out of there were your parents
supportive in all of this regularly they
couldn't believe it my dad is a really
funny guy like he actually did stand up
and stuff in the 80s or tried to do
stand-up and I went uh maybe I don't
know and he he's always incredibly funny
and so when I called him and told them I
got SNL I mean he passed out I mean he
couldn't believe it did you ever have
that weird thing where you like you kind
of go oh if I really owe this all to my
father like you're willing to sort of
give it up to your father your father
wasn't a successful standard no yeah
somehow you think like if I didn't have
him as a father I wouldn't be fine no
without a doubt I mean he he he exposed
me to really funny stuff at a really
young age and he would do funny like
legitimately really funny bits to people
and I would go oh that's it was like I
had a leg up on friends you know people
like I don't know Three's Company or
something at school and I was like no
Monty Python and you know spinal tap do
you ever worry that your dad's envious
of your success now because he sees you
doing your impressions and he probably
said oh if there was a Saturday Night
Live when I was alone not at all he's
not like that at all he's I I mean that
sincerely he's not that at all that's
the thing not even when he got stuck
behind the walls might have been tough
come on come on Smash him